مطالب في المانيا بتصنيف الحرس الثوري
الايراني منظمه ارهابيه بعد مساعد
بريطانيه لخطوه مماثل
تقول ان استخدام الجنودها لهواتفهم نقال
في مكيفك وسبب الرئيس للهجوم الاوكراني
تاجيله تصويت الجمهوريين على رئيس المجلس
النواب الى مسائل اليوم بعد فشلهم في
انتخابي مرشحين
[موسيقى]
اسعد الله صباحكم بكل خير اهلا بكم الى
نصره الله من العربي
تتزايد في الارض البرلماني الالمانيه
الايراني
وفي حوار مع صحيفه الفرنسيه اكد الباحث في
الشهور الايرانيه ين ريتشارد ان النظام
الايراني بامكانه ان يزيد من قبل احتجاجات
مشيرا في الوقت ذاته الى ثوره في ايران
بانها تجذب كل من يرفض عظله
رغم الضغوط والانتقادات الدوليه للنظام
الايراني
على رفع وتيره القمع ضد المتظاهرين خلال
الفتره المقبله النظام الايراني بامكانه
ان يزيد من قمع الاحتجاجات الكلام هنا
للباحث في الشؤون الايرانيه يا غشاغ في
مقابله مع صحيفه الفرنسيه صاحب كتاب
الشيطان الاكبر الشهوه والامام وضع مقارنه
بين وضع ايران ايام سنه قبل سقوطه اي عام
1978 وحال النظام الايراني حاليا وخلص الى
ان الملالي في ايران يمثلون الطبقه
متماسكه الى حد ما مضيفا ان الخلافات
الداخليه بما في ذلك في صفوف الحرس الثوري
تظهر ان القمع الشرسه لم يعد بالاجماع
لكنه قد يتطور اكثر
الباحث ذاته يعتبر ما سماها بالثوره في
ايران تجذب كل اولئك الذين يرون ان فساد
قادتهم وعدم كفائهم تسبب بالركود والعزله
الدوليه مضيفا ان الامر سيتطلب المزيد
لتغيير النظام لكن في المقابل يمكن ان
يزيد من تكثيف القمع يا غشاغ اضاف ايضا ان
اداء الامريكيين يعزز اكثر نظام الايراني
ويدفعه الى طلب الحمايه الروسيه خاصه في
المجال العسكري ما يجعل المحتجين يستنكرون
هذه التدخلات بالنظر الى التكلفه الباهظه
التي تترتب عنها وفقا الباحث نفسه بلال
البشتيني العربيه
ذكرت وسائل الاعلام الايرانيه انه سلطات
القضائيه في طهران مواجهه التهابات
لمواطنين فرنسيين
ومعهما مواطن بلجيكي بالتجسس والعمل ضد
الامن القومي الايراني
ضمن حمله الاعتقالات العشوائيه التي
تنفذها سلطات الامنيه بتهمه التحريض
واثارها
[موسيقى]
ايضا وصلت لاعبه الشطرنج الايرانيه ساره
خادمه الى اسبانيا لطلبه
وكاله رويترز انطلقت مكالمات هاتفيه
متعدده من افراد قريبين منها حضروها من
العوده الى ايران
من قبل
ظهورها بدون حجاب في العاب الشطرنج
وفي ذكرى مقتله اظهرت صور متداوله اضراب
محتاجين اضرامهم النيران في صوره قاسم
سليمان قائد فيلق القدس تابعه للحرس
الثوري بطهران وفي مدينه مراغه بمحافظه
اذربيجان الشرقي
[موسيقى]
اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ارتفاعها
حصيله الهجوم الاوكرانيه على مكان الى 89
قتيلا من الجنود الروسي
للهجوم هو استخدام الجنود للهواتف
المحموله على نحو غير مصرح به واضافه
الوزاره
الجندي المجهول تحميل بقدر الحزن السيايا
ومطالبه باجابات عن موته كان من الممكن
تفاديه وخصوصا ان الاهالي يتهمون القيادات
العسكريه بالتقصير وعدم توفير الحمايه
اللازمه للمجندين خصوصا بعد قرار السماحي
باستخدام الهواتف في ما سهاما في تحديد
القوات الاوكرانيه لموقعهما مقابله مطالب
الاهالي يبرز وعيد سياسي وبرلماني يطالب
بمعقبه القاده العسكريين بتهمه تجاهل
المخاطر مدون عسكري روسي يتابعه اكثر من
700,000 شخص على تيليجرام وصف لاستهدافه
بالمروعه والقاب اللوم على قاده الجيش
الروسي
من الذي اتى بفكره وضع مجندين باعداد
كبيره في مبنى واحد في اي استهداف سيخلف
الكثير من القتل والجرحى يقول خبراء
عسكريون روز ان الهجوم الاوكراني الذي نفذ
في صواريخهم اسكباروسيا خساره هي الافدح
عسكريا ومعنويا خصوصا من ناحيه تاثير على
اقبال الشبان الروس على تجنيد اضافه الى
تعثر الحمله العسكريه التي اقتربت من
انهاء عامها الاول بدون اي انجازات تذكر
وفي اخر تطورات المعارك الميدانيه تعرضت
مدينه
مجاوره لها لقصف عنيف من قبل قوات القوات
الاوكرانيه خلف القصف الاوكرانيه على 17
اصابه
مركز التجنيد الروسي في دنسكي ضربات اهمها
قصف قاعده التجنيد العسكريه يتواجد بها
قرابه 200 جندي اوكراني في منطقه درود
على مواقع للقوات الروسيه خلال ال 24 ساعه
الماضيه واشاره الجيش الاوكراني في بيانه
الى احباط محاوله الروسيه في 15 منطقه
اليمنى من نهر
ضربات الجويه والصاروخيه الروسيه على
البنيه التحتيه الحيويه في اوكرانيا
كما اعلنت القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه ان
الجيش الاوكرانيه اسقطا نحو 500 الطائره
بدون طيار ايرانيه الصنع منذ سبتمبر
الماضي وكده المتحدث باسم القوات الجويه
الاوكرانيه ان القوات الدفاع الجوي دمرت
جميع الطائرات المسيره التي اطلقتها روسيا
في هجومها المكثف خلال عطله راس السنه
والتي بلغ عددها 84 طائره
ارجو مجلس النواب الامريكيه الى مساء
اليوم جلسه انتخابي رئيس وذلك بعد ثلاث
جولات اقتراع فشلت خلالها الاغلبيه
الجمهوريه في حشد الاصوات اللازمه
لانتخابي مرشحها كيفما كارتي رئيس المجلس
وذلك في سابقه منذ ما يقرب من 100 عام و
خلال جولات الاختراع الثلاثه المتتاليه
فشل المكارفي النائب عن ولايه كاليفورنيا
في اقناعه من زملائه من مؤيدي الرئيس
السابق بانتقابه خلفان لنانسي
اكثر مما ينبغي تعكس هذه النتيجه الخلافات
في صفوف الجمهوريين الذين فازوا بالاغلبيه
في مجلس النواب بعد انتخابات منتصف
الولايه
هاني هاني
لكن البدايه تعثرت فالرجل الطامح في منصب
نانسي فلوس كرئيس للاغلبيه في مجلس النواب
لم يضمن الرقم السحري وهو
لتطبيق جدتهم التي تسودها نظريات المؤامره
مفاوضات خلف الابواب المغلقه في اللحظات
الاخيره في محاولات لتفادي اجراء جوله
اعاده التصويت على اهم منصب للجمهوريين
استردوهم مناسب لوسي حيث لم يتم التصويت
على اختراع الاعاده منذ 100 عام كان هدفي
عام
وكوادر الحزب الجمهوري للسنوات القادمه
في حزب الجمهوريه الجميع يعتبر نفسه
محافظا لكن السؤال هو اي نوع من المحافظين
هناك مثلا ما يسمى بتجمع الحريه وهم
الاكثر موالاه لدونالد ترامب داخل الحزب
وهم يعرضون مكارث وعندما تكون هناك اغلبيه
باربعه اصوات لا يمكن انتخابه بامتناع
السته نوابنا من حسبه
[تصفيق]
الجمهوريين بمعركه رئاسه الكونجرس وتاخرهم
عن فتح لجان تحقيق وعد بها سواء كانت في
الخروج الذي وصف بالمهين لاداره بيض من
افغانستان او ملفاته هانتر وعلاقته مع
شركات صينيه او حتى صلاحيات الرئيس لاداره
البلاد
[موسيقى]
خلافاتهم فعل الرئيس التعامل مع كونغرس
المنقسم لاول مره ولم يستطيع تمريرا
مشاريع كبرى كما فعل على مدى العامين
السابقين لكنه خلافات الجمهوريين تثلج صدر
الرئيس والديمقراطيين في القاهره
ايضا في هذه النشره ولكن بعد قليل
النصر يقدمون نجمه العالمي كريستيانو
رونالدو تحديدا
للشباب والرياضه وزيره للدفاع ثم وزيره
للداخليه ووزيره للعدل قبل ان تتسلم حقيبه
الخارجيه العام 2010
[موسيقى]
جون سينا جميع
ا
حزبيه وبين سلطه ومعارضه
الذاكره السياسيه الجزء الاول الجمعه
العاشره والنصف على شاشه العربيه
[موسيقى]
تلفزيون او تصفح وسائل الاعلام وترغب في
معرفه اخر المستجدات الاقليميه والدوليه
[موسيقى]
الاقتصاديه والرياضيات من قناه العربيه
على اليكسا باللغه العربيه
[موسيقى]
هذه ابرز اخبارنا من العربيه
اهلا بكم من جديد طلبه دوله الامارات
والصين عقد اجتماع عالمي لمجلس الامن
لمناقشه التطورات الاخيره في المسجد
الاقصى حسب دبلوماسيين قبل ذلك قال الرسول
في مكتب رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي
في المسجد الاقصى وذلك بعد اقتحام وزير
الامن القومي
رجعتي قال البيت الابيض ان الولايات
المتحده تويدو بحزم الحفاظ على الوضع
الراهن للمواقع المقدسه في القدس واعرب
البيت الابيض عن رفضه اي تغيير في الوضع
القائم بهذه المواقع بدورها حضرت وزاره
الخارجيه الامريكيه من زياده التوترات
والعنف بسبب اقتحام وزير الامن القومي
الاسرائيلي اطمار بن غفير لباحات المسجد
الاقصى
على واقع الاقتحام الاستفزازي لوزير الامن
القومي الاسرائيلي بنج فير مساحات المسجد
الاقصى سرعه اسرائيل الى رفع حاله التاهب
خاصه على حدود قطاع غزه خشيه من اطلاق
صواريخ وخوفا من عدم اختصار ردود الفعل
الشعبيه والرسميه الفلسطينيه على بيانات
التمديد والاستنكار الشعب الفلسطيني الذي
يرضى بتمرير هذه الجرائم اليوميه من
اقتحامات للاقصى وكانت الاقتحامات تتم على
يد المستوطنين الان تتم اعياد الحكومه
ان يضع قواعد جديده للعبه المسجد الاقصى
المبارك وانا اقول انه سيتحمل المسؤوليه
عن نتائج هذه اللعبه لان اللعب بالمسجد
الاقصى المبارك هو بالعاده العب بالنار
بالتجربه منذ عام 67 حتى اللحظه وكان
الوزير المتطرف بين كبير لجا الى نوع من
الخدعه حيث اشعه ان اقتحامه الاقصى تاجل
بعد تحفظ نتياه لكن الرجل لين كانت تفاعل
الاقتحام بقالنا وتم مده 13 دقيقه فقط
بشكل غير معلن اما نتنياه فتجاهل الحديث
عن الاقتحام في جلسه الحكومه وفضل التحدث
عن ايران
الاتفاق النووي الخطير شطب عن طاوله البحث
بعد الاحداث الاخيره في ايران اعتقد بان
هذه الامكانيه ما زالت قائمه ولم تنتهي
في حكومه انا عضو فيها لا تكون هناك تفرقه
عنصريه اليهود سيصعدون لجبل الهيكل ونوضح
لحماس اننا لن نتراجع وفي العوده الى
الاقتحام فان بين كبير سبق وانت سبب
بالحرب الاخيره على قطاع غزه بعد
اقتحاماتها متكرره لساحات الاقصى وحي
الشيخ جراح لكن الاقتحام الحالي يبدو
مغيرا بعد ان اصبح في موقع صنع قرار يعرف
بن كبير في اسرائيل بانه مشعله حرائق
التقليديه وقد وضع حاليا بالقرب من برميل
من عروض واقتحامه للمسجد الاقصى سيصب
الزيت على نار المواجهه مع الفلسطينيين
الذين يقولون بان التطرف لم يعد تصريحات
او شعارات وان ممارسه على الارض زياد حلبي
العربيه القدس الشرقيه المحتله
توجه بريطانيا
سلسله من اضرابات القطارات حتى الان حيث
استثمر الاضرابات خمسه ايام متتاليه في
شهر يناير الحالي
والسكك الحديديه والبحريه والنقل اضرابين
مده كل واحد منهما 84 ساعه في ثالث الرابع
والسادس وسابع من يناير اضافه الى اضراب
نقابه رجال الاطفاء في الخامس من الشهر
الحالي
وتمثل الاضرابات
بين النقابات
واربع استمرار تداعيات اضراب الممرضين
طالب رؤساء ومسروع الصحه البريطانيين
المواطنين بالابتعاد عن مراجعه المستشفيات
والمراكز الصحيه في حال لم تكن الحاله
المرضيه سيئه
ارتفاع الحراره
من توفير الرعايه الصحيه ويعرض حياه الناس
لخطر اسوا ما كان عليه في ذروه جائه
كورونا تحذير اطلقه المسؤولون في قطاع
الصحه
لا يمكننا الاستمرار بهذا الشكل حتى لا
نقول العام المقبل
على الصحه العامه
على خلفيه هذا التحذيري ومخاوث من ان تزيد
عوده التلاميذ الى المدارس الضغط على
النظام الصحي اصدرت وكاله الامن الصحفي
بريطانيا نصائح بابقاء من يعاني من حمى في
المنزل لتجنب اصابه الاخرين وارتداء
كمامات في حال الاضطرار الى الخروج
والتجنب خدمات الصحه الا في الظروف القصوى
بسبب تزايد اعداد مرضى المستشفيات
بالانفلونزا وكرونا والحمى القرمزيه التي
وصلت الى ما يقارب 10,000 مريض هذا الى
جانب اوقات الانتظار الطويله التي قد تؤدي
الى وفاه خمس مئه شخص في الاسبوع بسبب
التاخير في رعايه الطوارئ بحسب الكليه
الملكيه لطب طوارئ
الحذر الشديد عندما تنظر الى ارقام
الوفيات الزائده واذا عقدنا مقارنه دوليه
سنجد ان العديد من الانظمه الصحيه بعد
خروجها من جائ كورنا تشهد معدلات وفايات
اعلى من ما تتوقعه تقليديا وهذا هو الحال
في المانيا وايطاليا واسبانيا
تحذير مسؤولي الصحه يعكس الضغط الكبير في
الخطوط الاماميه لقطاع الصحه قبل جائزه
كورونا والذي يعاني من نقص في كوادره
وقائمه انتظار وصلت لاول مره الى سبعه
ملايين مريض
لم يسبق لهيئه الخدمات الصحيه في بريطانيا
ان عاشت ازمه مماثله منذ تسنيات القرن
الماضي بالرغم من ضخم الملياراته في قطاع
الصحه ولا يبدو حل مشاكله في المستقبل
المنظور لملئ الوظائف الشاغره وتقليس
قوائم الانتظار الطويله مصطفى زاروه
العربيه
قدم نادي النصر السعودي نجمه الجديد
كريستيانو رونالدو في ملعب مرسول مبارك في
حفل الحضره 30 المتفرج و خلال المؤتمر
الصحفي لتقديم الصفقه الاسطوريه قال
رونالدو انه اختار نادي النصر رقم العروض
الاوروبيه التي قدمت له وهكذا الدوري
السعودي
اذا قرر المدرب ذلك
في ثقافه النادي
وسعاده
[موسيقى]
في الختام تذكير بالعناوب
مطالبه في المانيا بتصنيف الحرس الثوري
الايراني منظمه ارهابيه بعد مساءا
بريطانيه لخطوه الممثله
تقول ان استخدام جنودها لهواتفهم انا قال
في مكيف هو سبب الرئيسي للهجوم الاوكراني
وتجيله تصويت الجمهوريين على رئيس المجلس
النواب الى مساء اليوم بعد فشلهم في
انتخابي مرشحه
نهايه
[موسيقى]